Tulsi gabbard is a former member of
Congress from Hawaii who from the very
first day from February 24th when this
War Began says been saying the exact
same thing which is the stakes are very
high here maybe we should acknowledge
that before we proceed heedlessly
forward we're honored to have her join
us again tonight Congressman woman thank
you so much for coming on what what do
you make of this
we're reminded once again Tucker that we
are unfortunately being led by leaders
who are selfish and short-sighted and
don't care about the American people
they are leading us further and further
into war without understanding one of
the most basic tenets and
characteristics of War which is it is
unpredictable
uh once that first shot is fired once
that first punch is thrown the the
predictable nature of things you can
plan for things but it by Nature becomes
unpredictable and so they're they're
like oh my gosh this thing has become
sabotage well yeah war is unpredictable
the thing that is not unpredictable
however is the cost of war the suffering
the devastation the destruction the
death that is caused by it and so the
real question for the American people
and for us to ask our leaders is how
much suffering will we have to endure
here in this country and for people
around the world because as you've so
clearly stated we see a sabotage of an
energy pipeline today
what's next is it access to the internet
is it satellites that are connected to
GPS that power virtually all parts of
our life and also our weapon systems go
on down the line and we end up with this
potential nuclear outcome and so you
know our leaders are saying well hey we
can't do anything this is all in Putin's
hands well guess what the United States
our leaders and European leaders are the
ones fueling and funding this war so
they have a heck of a lot of Leverage to
be able to push for a ceasefire
negotiated outcome and an end to this
war and to actually fight for peace and
prosperity and we need to know that if
they're not doing that and they aren't
right now then what they are doing is
pushing for more destruction more war
and therefore a lack of peace and
prosperity and more suffering for us and
people around the world
if it turns out that the Biden
Administration actually blew up a
natural gas pipeline or okayed someone
else's sabotage of that pipeline
shouldn't there be a federal law that
prevents them from lecturing the rest of
us about climate change ever again
I I I don't have the evidence of who was
responsible for this uh there there will
be consequences if that is ever found
out but we have the reality of what
we're dealing with right before us today
which is if we continue down this path
we may end up with a nuclear Holocaust
and so for us and for millions of people
around the world what are we going to do
about it we've got to call on our
leaders to actually take a stand and
fight for peace fight for Prosperity
fight for our future
yeah I mean you kind of like your kids
to be able to grow up and stuff like
that exactly gabbard like stuff like
that yeah stuff like that I appreciate
coming on as always thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight